Game of Thrones star Emilia Clarke is
opening up about how she survived
life-threatening health scares in an
essay for The New Yorker the 32 year old
actress revealed she survived two brain
aneurism aneurysms one of which ruptured
and complications from a failed brain
surgery she wrote she had been through a
war more gruesome than any that her Game
of Thrones character had experienced she
told The New Yorker Radio Hour she was
at the gym eight years ago when she
actually felt the rupture I mean then
I'm doing the plank and and I suddenly
get this unbelievable pain and that felt
very much like an elastic band around my
brain excruciating and whilst you know
you're used to things hurting in the gym
I was pretty aware quite early on that
that wasn't normal Wow our dr. David
agus is here to explain what happened to
her and how the doctors treated her I
mean she's what she says David is
graphic and terrifying she says it was
shooting stabbing constricting pain and
that she knew that her brain had been
damaged I'm really glad that she's
telling this story but I was surprised
that it happened to someone in their
early 20s it can happen in any age I
mean more common in the sixth decade and
beyond at any age but what she described
is called a thunderclap headache because
it goes all of a sudden it gets turned
on I mean she had a rupture and a bleed
she then went to the bathroom and
actually collapsed in the stall and
that's the most lucky thing if somebody
was there to call 9-1-1 because 40% of
these are deadly in people who have
these kind of hemorrhages and these kind
of aneurysms the burst symptoms other
symptoms that signal that you might have
this in some people I mean they can have
you know slight headaches going in they
can have visual changes in others but
you know when it hits it hits and you
know it
so is this genetic or is it from
lifestyle what causes them the answer is
yes to all of them there's a genetic
component we think - about 20% of them
smoking high blood pressure stress can
be a component of it you know if you've
had one you're much more likely to have
others and you need to be followed she
will be followed with MRIs on a regular
basis for the rest of her life
are there any warning signs that lead up
to something that can prevent an act
you know she talks in in The New Yorker
article about having you know headaches
and some symptoms which may or may not
been related
you know it's an aneurysm so you have
this artery in the brain and then the
wall gets weak and it balloons out and
then when it ruptures and blood comes
out that's when the dramatic side
effects happen so in most people it's
silent until it ruptures
she says she feels a hundred percent I
mean he's had that her being overly
optimistic or does the brain bounce back
the Brad's and well especially in a
twenty or thirty year old right right
you know in you and I we're past that
point I mean so when it happens when
you're older the we're not as you know
resilient but that being said I mean she
has a risk of seizure later in life I
mean that caused scar tissue scar tissue
means that electrical circuit in the
brain can have seizures she's gonna be
monitored for other aneurysms to me
she's a hero though she stepped up and
was vulnerable and she said hey listen I
had this disease I want others to learn
about the experiences I had and I want
to demystify it that's the definition of
the huge caller brave for speaking up uh
it really is powerful until the last
decade or so you know celebrities never
talked about their weaknesses it you
know are you gonna hire someone for a
movie who may have another one of these
so there's vulnerability there and she
took it head-on and to me that's power
she had two surgeries one that replaced
part of her skull with titanium I mean
how high is she at a significantly
greater risk of having this happen again
oh no question about it cuz she had two
of them I mean the first one they went
up through the groin through the femoral
artery all the way to the brain and they
put a coil in you know that coil caused
it to clot off the second one they tried
that but it bled and so they had to go
into the skull and go in that way to
clip it off well so these are major
surgeries that require crazy technology
we've been talking about strokes the
past few weeks with the passing of Luke
Perry and you say there's a connection
between an aneurysm and a stroke what is
that so when the aneurysm ruptures
that's a type of stroke and basically
the artery spasms down and limits blood
supply to the brain even though there's
a bleed in part of the brain and so
that's what we call a hemorrhagic stroke
so it's a subtype of the strokes well we
are very fortunate that amelia is alive
well brave of her to walk thinking out
about this doctor David egg it's great
to see you thank you so much